bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
lui io sono qua dj che oggi siamo
tornati su youtubers life non facevo da
oltre una settimana tra l'altro che poi
ho fatto il video con la play 3 comprata
coi miei soldi sudati castoro avevo
davvero fatto questo video nell'ultimo
episodio ma che il calcio mi avete detto
tutti quanti che poi mi sembra mi sento
io stupido c'è l'italiano ma cazzo mai
giocato sto gioco in inglese c'era in
italiano ma veramente sono 200 episodi
che faccio su sta roba e c'era in
italiano allora carica a sto cazzo di
video che la gente si sta di scriverlo
senza un us metti di ballare sulla
playstation non presta io la uccido la
non anomala squarto vivace magia ma stai
bene
collabora in un video am sono fermi dei
due un video in coop
perché la coop sei tu famoso video così
starò perché arrivano faqih quanto so
l'importante ha ricevuto una targa di
youtube ma veramente a perché sono 144
mila iscritti giusto i commenti in
italiano fatemi legge sta roba non posso
credere che un autoproclamato youtuber
sia così incapace nel editing vai dei
corsi per te stesso e per gli altri
insegnanti viaggiano individuano
linguaggi con gli anni la fa vigeva gli
invitati al cinema questa sera ma se
stai a ballare a tutto il giorno ma che
cazzo dici va bene ci siamo ragazzi ma
veramente no ma sei serio fa brutta
strada a quei questa una limonata basta
ma quanta roba sta succedendo lo che
stava mi stacco pia cup ma non ci fosse
mai identico una ma tu lo sapevi
miranda questa qua lo sapeva che mi
sarei messo cappelle assurdo non vorrei
che si ingelosisce la mia tizia rai li
lasciamo perdere
monari i muri registra in terapia perché
posso intervistare lei ma come
intervistiamo ciao riley come stai
ma perché tra l'altro nelle miniature a
parigi safety car ma che senso ha
scemi ma che bug nome ragazza da quando
ho messo la lingua italiana sto gioco
qua non si sta riprendendo e ve lo dico
entra
dai famosi testo adesso puoi uscire fa
vj grazie per essere venuto guarda se io
ti ringrazio questa frase avrei
preferito mela dicesse una donna da
vicino dire ho sbagliato fermo c'è la
notizia quella che mi ha frenato vicino
a lei dice divertiti minchia rosicava di
brutto che bello il tasto me ne vado non
potevano metterlo anche a scuola questo
vi sarebbe stato super utile ai ragazzi
facciamo sta roba in collaborazione che
ancora hanno capito facciamo collabora
in un video collaborazione dice video
dai fa mostra roba per l'amor di dio
ciao tipo me contro te ragazzi c'è una
roba ma sta facendo ma basta vieni che
dobbiamo fare il video brutta the
feature fantastico incredibile sì ma
dovete nella lista in piedi ai spuntato
uno sgabello a caso che teneri mi piace
solo penso quanto lo prendo nata sta
tizia mi viene male
sì ma che cazzo il videogioco state
giocando che lei sta con joystick e tu
con la tastiera grava limone limone duro
non c'è la schedina per limon arla ok
monto ios e tranquilla zia è la madonna
ma che cazzo sgabello tattico perché
cazzo già sotto la scrivania un cestino
quindi se io capovolgo il cestino e ci
faccio sedere una [ __ ] quella la fai
video con me va bene non fa niente non
scopriremo più avanti che sono qua c'è
una scheda ma no dov'è il programma di
editing che cazzo si è pagato ma dai ma
veramente ma vedi caligo italiana porta
sfiga ma veramente chi si è vaga ma
[ __ ]
non ci credo mai mi si è bagnato gioco
di mortacci sua lo sapevo io mi è
tornato sul desktop e non mi si apriva
più il video fa notare di miche l'ho
perso
lo penso che nervi non avete idea che
nervi pensa e va bene quanto bello sto
video
e pensare che prima era uscito da dio è
certamente era uscito molto meglio
honey proposta pubblicitaria proposte
pubblicitarie 500 vigenti per ti scrivo
per conto della mia compagnia o nei
abbiamo guardati dividerci piacerebbe
che facessi un video di collaborazione
con il nostro ottimo gioco retro leezer
per ogni impisi easy peasy riceverà il
gioco ancora che ne pensi vai all asta
giocà playstation mi chiama fa qualcosa
esci di casa gioca pokémon ghoga
a easy one easy peasy questa cosa un
cazzo tra l'altro mila contro jesi
compro nuovo pc ottieni i soldi per
comprare i componenti di base e aprì una
nuova postazione di lavoro a casa tua
quando quando quando hai soldi seleziona
una postazione compra il computer va
bene a posso mettere un compito quart
miti a 500 dollari stu grande cast
dell'india per di peso confavi j
gli effetti sono videogioco non ci
stanno con l'audio li fa lui con la
bocca
che cosa sei beatboxer ci siano ragazzi
ci sia questo video sarà una bomba mamma
vera ragazzi tutti i record tutti 148
1600 1100 1600 come contenuti non era
record ho fatto più di 1600 michia 1600
è assurdo come cazzo fate fare piu nuovo
liver ma video della vita perdi preso
confavi c'è una festa ciao fa vj come
[ __ ] vj ma questa guerra quella che mi
hanno frenato ma brutta brutta nema
levati doc collaborazione per il
ritrovato uno screen qualcuno di voi
ragazzi ha voglia di spiegarmi come
cazzo faccia fare una coop con la psp
cioè cos'è sta roba collaborazione
questo inizia e hanno dato dei soldi per
fare questo video vi venduti cancri scan
grease falsi dei big views scandalo
clicca qui
ecco la stati fatti cos'è cos'è a ma ce
l'avete due sì vabbè ma che tristezza
bellissima la webcam ci sono lo vorrei
come sbircia nove ragazzi finito vediamo
se riesco a fare un video dei centri
chiama fanno 200.000 views i miei video
adesso pubblica video vediamo
game over un altro mese e senza pagare
le bollette o sbagliato la mia storia
non è andata così mi dispiace ma questa
partita è terminata dovreste iniziare di
nuovo in che senso
cioè una no no no non è non è vero ma se
teschio
ma [ __ ] dall'inizio che cazzo io
registrati a fare gli ultimi sei episodi
allora ragazzi vi faccio questa premessa
qua ho stoppato il video ho cercato in
qualsiasi modo anche cercando guide su
internet di risolvere i precetti di tipo
di salvare questo problema ma nessuno è
riuscito a salvare questo problema
allora che cosa ho fatto preso dalla
disperazione o tipo provato a cancellare
ripescare i salvataggi vecchi di del
gioco e ci sono riuscito ho dovuto
andare nella cartella prende di
salvataggi dell'altro episodio e
caricarli di nuovo macello questa è
stata la mia espressione quando ci sono
riuscito perché non ci credevo neanche
io
[Musica]
giù le mani di a voi cazzo di joystiq
dobbiamo pagare le bollette ferma lì per
gli datemi monet che se no mi sbattono
fuori di casa devo pagare ma cosa è
successo devo pagare le bollette va bene
pago quello che cazzo vuoi lavora lavora
lavora vai a volare [ __ ] siamo
ritornati borga [ __ ]
oddio oddio grazie l'importante è
riusciti a far sta stronzata perché
veramente ungere dovrei riparare il
computer ma non mi è rimasto neuro
quindi va bene
saluti voglio farti sapere che ho
chiarato il tuo telefono e ho rubato
tutte le tue foto se non mi paghi 20
dollari li caricano su internet niente
di personale solo affari no le foto di
mia nonna nuda le tue foto non sono
state pubblicate ma ora sei sulla lista
nera ora l'ulker po chiederti soldi
quando vuole ciao amico ma [ __ ]
roma ma tanto i ragazzi cioè il piano di
sopra che ancora non ho visto la ci sono
mai andato al piano di sopra
posso mettere un altro computer voi da
altre molto più figo quassù che qualche
e giù padre ma quant'è bello la somma
perché non fai dovrà sopra qualcuno sono
alla porta o che a sorpresa 6 fa vj sono
nè girl scout e vabbè ma perché questa
qua ha bussato alla mia porta e si è
trovato a fa vj ma cazzo sto vendendo
nei biscotti certo che te li compro
basta che non deciso che col suo abito e
non fai niente per migliorare le
relazioni queste finire le relazioni la
conosce quella magia e ma vedi i testi
deficienti gente che manco conosco le
relazioni mason esce mai su tutte
fidanzate sono quando cioè gli iscritti
agli interessi e faceva un po cagare
però
pubblica video prodotto piazza basta
[ __ ] nova ecco brava torna indietro e
sta qua che continuano a questa qua
veramente sono miccia delle malattie hai
voglia di chattare oggi ha mai veramente
calcato il cazzo tutte così le donne ott
i fringe zona non puoi ti richiamano
perché ci ripensa e roma abate na fa
alcuna di ba pesante propria famiglia e
vorrei invitarti al chino allora sentite
dobbiamo capirci perché non ci stiamo
capendo chi devi levare dal cas ti devi
prendere buttare nel cesso non hai
capito con propri pc di base speso 500
euro per un computer mi fate vedere come
ciao vengo dalla compagnia elettrica
devo cambiare contatore entra quindi
mentre compagnia a sostituire il
contatore che ti ha chiesto 120 dollari
ciao amico ma perché tutti quelli che mi
prendono dei soldi mi chiamano amico dai
ragazzi per adesso concluso quinto
episodio perché dio mio
ho quasi rischiato di perdere
definitivamente in questo quindi ragazzi
mentre la tizia continua a ballar mi nel
salotto senza un perché un per come un
per quando malaika manetta proprio
voglio per il salvataggio che ho
recuperato perché non so manco io come
ho fatto incredibile anche a pagina di
facebook e come nel video prescrizione
cioè non siete ancora iscritti
iscrivetevi che ci vediamo un prossimo
vinto bene ragazzi